i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola que tal bienvenidos a diario de
compás el programa de france 24 en el
que analizamos el desarrollo de la
eurocopa de la copa américa estos son
nuestros titulares
ahora si el venció a perú con un gol de
lucas para que detalles el primer
finalista de la copa américa a la
canarinha mostró una gran primera parte
frente a una blanca y roja que reaccionó
en el segundo tiempo analizamos el
partido
colombia y argentina definen este martes
quien será el rival de brasil en la
final del maracaná el sábado albiceleste
se aferra al gran nivel de messi los
cafeteros respiran por el regreso de
juan guillermo cuadrado como ha sido el
desempeño de ambas selecciones hasta
estas semifinales
comienza la denominada ´final four´ en
wembley italia y españa- se citan en el
estadio londinense para definir al
primer finalista de la europa
saravia es baja confirmada con la roja y
la azzurra hace frente a la ausencia de
espinas hola es un duelo entre una gran
favorita y un equipo irregular
reid al final de la euro y la copa
américa vamos a empezar con la copa
américa y antes es un placer para mí
saludar un día más a sara castro
directora del diario 'as' colombia un
gusto estar con ustedes como siempre
ahora vamos a empezar con brasil porque
es el primer finalista de esta copa
américa a noche la canarinha se impuso
en río de janeiro a perú con un gol en
la primera parte de lucas para que está
para haber avanzar por segunda edición
consecutiva a la final del torneo
continental se hará gran primera parte
de brasil frente a una mejora de perú en
el período complementario como decíamos
en titulares
podemos decir que brasil fue a menos o
que perú fue a más en este partido yo
diría que ambas cosas lo primero es que
ayer ricardo gareca intentó un sistema
de cinco defensas que no falló por el
hecho de ser conservador porque entiendo
la necesidad además con los antecedentes
que tenía pero enfrentando a brasil de
querer cuidar un poco sino que sí afectó
el funcionamiento fue muy difícil porque
además a ti te llevó a neymar a para que
está incluso a richarlyson a presionar
la salida de perú y no lograron tener la
pelota
momento que es lo que hace llegar a que
en el segundo tiempo el cambia el
sistema totalmente paso en 4 4 2 o 4 4
11 dependiendo de la situación y esto lo
que hace es que el equipo se pone más
compacto que empieza a sacar mejor el
balón y eso complicó además el juego
interno de brasil entonces creo que se
vieron ambos temas adicional a esto ti
te también mencionó el desgaste que jet
que traía este brasil que en el último
partido en el anterior había tenido que
jugarlo con 10 y durante gran parte del
tiempo y creo que eso se vio reflejado
una vez más el campo de juego no estaba
en condiciones así que bueno brasil
sigue demostrando que tiene una idea muy
clara y los otros intentan competir y me
parece que el partido de pérez digno es
un partido digno pero sí que da esa
sensación de que está brasil es un poco
vulnerable si podemos decirlo así pero
siendo vulnerable o no el que volvió a
destacar por encima de todos es neymar y
de su el gol salió de una jugada suya de
un balón que él peleó y dice que quiere
enfrentarse contra argentina en la final
87% de precisión en los pases para
neymar esa asistencia que además es un
aspecto
por cómo se saca dos defensas y estamos
viendo un neymar en el que ti te está
aprovechando mucho de ese juego interno
que le está haciendo en el psg esto se
llama un jugador de arco y flecha es un
jugador que crea y define y lo que
estamos viendo además es esa alegría de
su técnica que pone al servicio del
colectivo y que invita a jugar entonces
pareciera que sólo necesita unos
momentos de chispazos pero la verdad lo
que hemos visto es fantástico luego
después de tantas críticas a que la
gambeta desapareció en sudamérica es el
jugador que más gambetas ha completado
en este torneo 51 y esto habla de la
alegría de su juego y sobre todo esa
necesidad de hacer jugar mejor a sus
compañeros este sistema de ti te es
cuestionado porque ata a muchos
jugadores a eso no a una necesidad de
conservar un orden pero creo que lo que
está haciendo neymar es fantástico así
es ahora vamos a pasar a hablar ya del
otro encuentro que tenemos para esta
noche la otra semifinal
colombia-argentina se enfrentan en
brasilia para definir al otro finalista
vamos a empezar hablando de argentina
porque el equipo del caroní ha contado
todo este torneo con una muy buena
versión de
en el mes y algunos le llaman un mes y
muy colectivo podemos decir que la mejor
versión de messi es esta que estamos
viendo en esta copa américa la verdad es
que scaloni después de dos años y
también después de muchas críticas ha
logrado que el equipo juegue no para
pasarles siempre la pelota messi sino
para dejarlo en condiciones de que él
pueda recibir y decidir si si juega con
una gambeta un pase corto un pase al
vacío pero no forzando lo no es siempre
pasándole la pelota meses sino generando
un ecosistema en el que él pueda brillar
y messi ha respondido ha respondido
desde el hambre competitiva que es
fundamental en estos torneos y también
desde un nivel individual impresionante
no es sino verlo como calcula el tiro
libre del último partido y realmente
estamos viendo a dos jugadores neymar y
messi majestuosos en este torneo y es
evidente ya lo decía neymar que él
quiere encontrarse con sus amigos en la
final que sería pues digamos que esa
final del clásico sudamericano que
quisiéramos ver evidentemente para
colombia eso entraría a complicarnos un
poco de tutela precisamente de ayudas
que ponía bueno me decidí manera final
es algo que con
diga que no tenemos que hablar también
del juego de colombia porque a reinaldo
rueda del defiende que tiene un juego en
donde se busca tener la posición de la
pelota y proponer el juego pero que ha
caracterizado el juego de colombia hasta
esta instancia de semifinales a mí me
parece que reinaldo llegó con esa
promesa reinaldo rueda con esa promesa
de devolverle eso que llamamos la
identidad el adn al fútbol colombiano
sin embargo hemos visto un equipo mucho
más práctico que eso el habla mucho de
mantener la posesión y de jugar bien a
la pelota pero creo que de colombia se
debe rescatar que con pocas unidades de
trabajo con este entrenador ha logrado
es resolver muy bien los partidos en
contra del sistema un 4-4-2 que le da
mucha versatilidad que puede tener un
equipo corto que ante equipos intensos
como uruguay lo hizo muy bien e insisto
se llegan a esos penales más por mérito
que por haber sufrido del partido y eso
es un envión anímico importante si no le
gana un equipo con jerarquía como
uruguay luego puede salirle a ser
partido a argentina fundamental la
concentración los primeros minutos que
es lo que cuesta con equipos grandes
como como éste y sobre todo
quien logre por fin estructurarse algún
sistema que conecte muy bien a los
delanteros que por fin podamos ver a
dwan zapata en ese nivel del atalanta un
poco teniendo más opciones y más
generación para que le haga beneficio a
su juego y aunque no tuvimos gol
precisamente hablando de esta versión de
ataque quizás esa versión es la mejor
versión de ataque la vimos en el partido
contra uruguay aunque no hubo goles sí
yo creo que lo de luís díaz es muy
importante ese desequilibrio que genera
por banda derecha vamos a ver si lo
mantienen por el rendimiento en el
partido anterior el que saldría debería
ser luis fernando muriel porque el
trabajo que ha hecho rafael santos
borrell es muy interesante es muy
interesante desde lo técnico y es muy
interesante desde lo táctico y podría
ser un muy buen socio con dual zapata
porque él siempre ha podido jugar como
segundo delantero entonces yo creo que
colombia ha ido construyendo eso y
reynaldo habla mucho de posesión pero lo
que más le valora en los otros
entrenadores es al contrario las
transiciones esa posibilidad de decidir
en jugadas rápidas y de agarrar digamos
aprovechar los espacios de equipos que
estén intentando atacar precisamente
escuchamos que dijeron un tanto de
lionel scaloni como reinaldo rueda
para lo que tenemos ganas de llegar a la
final ganas de ganar este partido y
y el hambre de estos jugadores ya es
evidente ellos están
concentrados casi dos meses llevamos
para esto y es más que evidente que
estamos todos con una ilusión bárbara
era algo que necesitábamos como cuerpo
técnico y que el grupo jugadores con su
receptividad con su trabajo y el gran
esfuerzo que han realizado nos han
colocado en esta posición es
importantísimo para colombia'
dentro de la aspiración que tenemos el
compromiso y el desafío que se ha fijado
el equipo de llegar a una final
pasamos a la eurocopa porque comienza la
denominada final four es afín a la 4 en
el estadio de wembley en londres italia
y españa- se miren a las 2 de la tarde
hora de bogotá limay quito y mañana el
turno es para en la tierra y dinamarca
en una final que también será en wembley
nos centramos en ese duelo entre italia
y españa- ahora es italia una súper
favorita para este partido a ver yo creo
que en este punto son los detalles e
incluso algunas decisiones las que van a
definir quién va a pasar en la final
cuál es la diferencia entre ambos
equipos evidentemente si nosotros
promediar amos las puntuaciones de ambos
equipos
italia ha tenido rendimientos mucho más
altos y sostenidos a lo largo del torneo
llegó con una idea muy clara quien grano
desde el primer día al contrario les
enrique también tiene una idea muy clara
pero ha necesitado hacer ajustes al
comienzo porque le faltaba su ficha
clave como era busquets y esa falta de
gol pero hoy en día son los más
goleadores del torneo entonces creo que
esa es la diferencia yo creo que desde
el planteamiento se conocen muy bien
ambos van a querer la posesión ambos van
a querer tener la pelota la diferencia
es que italia tiene un juego directo o
sea tiene más
referencias o cambios o variantes a la
hora de atacar mientras que españa
siempre va a depender mucho de la
posesión de la pelota incluso para
descender rápidamente y podemos decir
que esta españa es una españa que es
irregular por lo que hemos visto en el
torneo si no ha logrado de esos
rendimientos sostenidos pero por lo
mismo porque tiene fichas que encajan en
algunas ocasiones y sobre todo es que
los partidos nunca son de dominio
sostenidos y cuando se está sufriendo es
el momento en el que se pone a prueba la
idea mucho más que cuando se está en
dominio o en control del partido y hay
fichas por ejemplo pedrique ha tenido
momentos super brillantes pero a veces
también le cuesta pero tiene que ver con
eso es un equipo que necesita un poco
más de trabajo mientras que italia desde
el día 1 hasta hoy ha demostrado que
fluye mucho en el engranaje hoy que no
tendrá espinas sola que es un lateral
izquierdo y su ficha clave
veremos cómo logra solucionar pero en
general es un equipo que tiene una idea
absolutamente clara y definida
seguramente veremos un gran partido
además noticias sobre la eurocopa de la
copa américa que les presentamos a
continuación en diario de copas
precisamente el italiano leonard espinas
solas
sometió a una operación para reparar la
rotura en el tendón de aquiles de su
pierna izquierda que le impide estar con
sus compañeros en esta semifinal así lo
anunció la roma a su club y según su
nuevo entrenador jose mourinho espina
sola estará de baja varios meses
la uefa invitó al mediapunta danés
christian eriksen para que así está la
final de este domingo en wembley junto
con el equipo de paramédicos que lo
atendieron después de su colapso en el
debut de su selección en esta europa el
jugador del inter de milán se recupera
en su hogar y aún no ha confirmado si
así estará asistirá a ese encuentro
la confederación brasileña de fútbol
descartó cualquier riesgo para el
jugador lucas paquete a quien sufrió un
corte su pierna izquierda en una de las
últimas jugadas del partido contra perú
isidro campista del olympique de lyon se
encuentra bien y este martes hace parte
de la correspondiente recuperación con
sus compañeros
para muchísimas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros un día más ya mañana
conoceremos a otro finalista a otros
finalistas de la euro y la copa américa
gracias también ustedes por haber estado
con nosotros quédense porque hay más en
france24 france24 puntocom